i believe that for many people training
mobility will bring about more in terms
of functional movement gains than will
training strength that being said it's
far less common to hear people talking
about mobility or see them performing
mobility drills in the gym as compared
with lifting heavy weights the obvious
reason for this is that compared with
lifting weights stretching and doing
mobility drills isn't that glamorous and
can be a little bit boring but what if i
told you you could improve your mobility
without ever performing a single stretch
so here on the bioneer i'm all about
bang for your buck exercises why perform
an exercise that does one useful thing
when you could perform an exercise that
has 20 different benefits for you and a
great example of this is using movements
that build strength and mobility at the
exact same time so what i'm talking
about here is a form of weighted
stretching or loaded mobility however
it's not quite that because weighted
stretching or loaded mobility imply that
you're using weights to get into a
stretched position but that's the main
goal of the movement what i'm talking
about here is selecting specifically
those movements that target strength and
build a lot of strength and performance
but have the added benefit of also
improving your mobility so you're not
dedicating time to training mobility
you're just getting it as this nice side
effect so what we're looking at here is
movements that have a deep range of
motion affecting muscle groups that are
regularly tight and difficult to move so
if you remember i very recently talked
about the benefits of using a partial
range of motion now i'm talking about
the benefits of using an extreme range
of motion and as you can see they're
both useful so neither approach is going
to trump the other it's more about
combining them in useful and interesting
ways and the best part of this is that
you actually get superior benefits both
in terms of the strength and in terms of
the mobility because mobility as many of
you probably know by now is not the same
as flexibility flexibility is your
ability to get into a position however
is necessary so using someone else to
push you into that position or leaning
your leg up against a bar or even
pulling it there with your own arms
mobility is the ability to get yourself
into that position using just your own
effort so the strength is just as
important here as the elasticity of the
antagonistic muscles it's not
necessarily just about being flexible
it's about being strong enough to
overcome the resistance provided by the
antagonistic muscle and it's also about
being able to relax the antagonistic
muscle so that it's not tensing up and
preventing you from moving the way you
want to move this is something you can
learn and using weights is a great way
to do that so when you use a weight
you're getting deep into that position
but you're still using your strength
because you need to control the weight
and control that motion then you need to
lift yourself out of it again and at the
same time because you're using the
weight you can get yourself deeper into
that stretch than you otherwise would be
able to
you might also be able to improve your
tendon strength there's a study that
shows how performing heel dips weighted
heel dips but at a deficit so there's a
stretch on the calves can help to
improve tendinopathy at the same time
there might be hypertrophy and strength
benefits because you're training for a
greater range of motion thus creating
more opportunity for hypertrophy and in
a previous video on weighted stretching
i talked about the mounting anecdotal
evidence there is for the beneficial
effects of stretching during an exercise
we look at people like arnold
schwarzenegger who used pec flies with a
large range of motion would feel the
stretch and the burn in the pecs and
this would lead to greater size and by
getting greater strength and control in
deeper ranges of motion you can prevent
injury by controlling yourself when
you're slipping and falling and at the
same time you can power yourself through
from positions that would otherwise be
weakened thereby enhancing your athletic
performance so by just incorporating
some of these exercises that have a deep
range of motion including a weight you
can gain athletic benefits you can
improve your mobility and you can even
potentially help to strengthen and heal
your tendons so there's really no reason
not to experiment with this so of course
it wouldn't be very fair or helpful of
me to talk about how beneficial these
weighted stretches are without actually
demonstrating a few of my favorite ones
that you can incorporate into your
workouts
let's start with what i talked about in
my fortify workout video that being the
sumo squat and all you're gonna do here
is a squat with much wider legs and you
can either use your body weight as the
weight or you can hold an additional
dumbbell make sure that your toes and
your knees are lined up so you're not
splaying your toes out in a funny
direction
and then lower yourself to a point where
you feel that stretch on the insides of
the thighs
you can then add a leg lift at the top
of the movement if you like to make this
even more challenging and this way
you're strengthening and stretching both
the hip adductors and hip abductors
which is something that a lot of us are
once again lacking partly owing to the
fact that we simply don't move that much
in the frontal plane certainly not in
the gym and improving your hip mobility
and your strength this way will not only
help you to avoid falls if you're trail
running for example or just walking off
the beaten path you can also prevent
injuries by helping your knees attract
better so this is a great one to
incorporate
dead hangs are another great one for
improving shoulder mobility in
particular i talked about this very
recently in my shoulder video but
essentially what you're doing is just
stretching out the lats and the pecs and
maintaining this overhead position with
your arms what you want to do is a
passive dead hang which means that
you're just allowing your weight to
completely hang as much as possible if
you find this painful or difficult then
you can use a little bit of assistance
from your legs to begin with but the
idea is not to be actively engaging the
muscles to pull yourself up at all let
your shoulders shrug up by your ears in
terms of bang for your buck you're not
only building great grip strength by
doing this and not only decompressing
the spine there's nothing to stop you
from raising your leg of course here
once again your body is the weight but
there's also nothing stopping you from
holding weight between your knees or on
your feet if you want to make it a
little bit more of a intense stretch
[Music]
poor squat mobility can come down to
tight calves and ankles as well as hip
flexors and all kinds of other things
fortunately one of the best ways to
improve your squat mobility is just to
do lots of squats and if you aim to go
deep not to the point where it's
extremely uncomfortable just a little
bit deeper using a slightly lighter
weight so you can get out of that
position then the small amount of weight
on your shoulders or held in front of
you or wherever can help to push you a
little bit deeper and improve your
mobility that way
also surprisingly effective for squat
mobility is the pistol squat when you
perform a pistol squat you really have
no place to hide because if you don't
have the necessary mobility you're just
going to fall over particularly if you
don't have their ankle mobility you'd
like to fall backwards the great thing
about holding a weight at the same time
as doing this is that this will then
help you to ease into the deeper
position but at the same time it also
acts as a counterbalance so if you are a
bit back heavy it will then bring you
back forwards of course you can also use
the pistol squat by holding onto a wall
or a rope to balance or you can put one
foot up onto something higher which
makes the mobility challenge a little
bit easier and of course you can get
closer and closer to the ground over
time
then of course there's the cossack squat
which i'm a huge fan of we're
essentially doing a kind of side lunge
but heading all the way down keeping
your heel flat on the ground once again
and this trains all kinds of mobility as
well as strength and is a fantastic way
to build up to the pistol squat
the hamstring mobility one of the best
things you can do is the good morning
and here you're going to have the weight
on your shoulders maybe slightly lower
down then you're going to hinge at the
hips keeping the weight over the midline
of the foot you can start with just a
bar even you want to keep this very very
light and this of course will get a nice
stretch on the hamstrings once again
more than you can probably easily
achieve on your own but at the same time
it's also a great exercise for
strengthening the lower back and
teaching you the hip hinge movement
obviously you have things like the
jefferson curl which are fantastic for
this kind of pike mobility however if
we're looking at exercises that provide
other benefits and that aren't just all
about the mobility then i think that
this one is particularly effective and
it's something that a lot more people
are going to feel comfortable doing
also commonly missing for a lot of
people is thoracic mobility in the mid
spine if you're looking for an exercise
that can train this while at the same
time providing a bunch of other benefits
then look no further than the hindu
push-up in the hindu push-up you start
off in a kind of downward dog position
dive bomb towards the ground to a lower
press up position and then you lift your
chest up trying to extend the spine and
really focusing on making sure that
you're extending at the at the sternum
or just below the shoulder blades rather
than the lower back then you can return
to that starting position again if you
try and keep your heels mostly on the
ground at the same time then you'll also
get a nice hamstring and calf stretch in
here as well and of course you're also
getting all the benefits of a push-up
and another one that's great for
overhead shoulder mobility for
stretching the pecs and lats is the
dumbbell pullover which is also just a
great exercise for building the pecs and
lats i'm going to demonstrate you here
in the worst possible way
so that's the split squat which ben
patrick is a big fan of it's a fantastic
exercise not only for stretching the hip
flexors which is something that's
extremely tight on
ninety percent of desk workers but it's
also great for ankle mobility because
you're leaning forward so much at the
same time you're getting the benefits of
a squat it's great for building stronger
legs through a massive range of motion
and just watching ben patrick perform as
a testament to how powerful this
movement can be
he can dunk and all sorts of things but
you've also managed to get the scissor
split without stretching for it
specifically
and for the carves what you can do is a
car phrase but starting with a hill much
lower than the ball of your foot whether
you put it on a wedge or just pile up
some plates so you can feel the stretch
in the calf before you begin this is
also a great way to get stubborn calves
to grow
most of us already have the strength we
need to lift pretty much everything that
we lift regularly in our day-to-day
lives however if you're very tight in
your hamstrings if you've got tight
rounded shoulders and if you've got
tight hip flexors this creates all these
kind of compensatory movement patterns
and all these odd postures and now when
you try and exert that strength at an
awkward angle you can end up hurting
yourself because something is far more
likely to tear or pull if you don't have
that little bit of slack that little bit
of leeway to allow yourself to move in a
comfortable and free way i think so many
people could benefit from focusing on
this a little bit instead of just
thinking hey i want to get into shape
i'm just going to pile on lots and lots
of weight
so my goal at the moment in my training
is to improve my own mobility whilst
maintaining my strength and when you
start to do this you feel so much more
free you're able to move so much more
freely and you realize that a lot of
what you thought of is kind of tiredness
or fatigue it's actually just tightness
caused by sitting in the same position
all day and moving incorrectly once you
gain that mobility again once you relax
those muscles you feel liberated because
you're able to move so much more freely
you feel so much more energetic and you
can express that strength through a
greater range of motion i hope you found
this video useful interesting guys if
you did then please leave a like and
share around it helps me out so much and
i massively appreciate it if you like
this kind of training that looks not
only at strength and aesthetics but also
your overall performance and how you
move in the real world then you might
enjoy my ebook and training program
super functional training there's a
discount on right now and there's a link
in the description down below there you
can also find a link to my physical book
functional training and beyond which is
available for more goods bookstores
including amazon and that's an
introduction to functional training and
how it affects not only athletes but
everybody else so check it out if you're
interested either way thank you so much
for watching this one subscribe if you
want to see more like it hit the bell
button for notifications and i'll see
you next time
bye for now